الخرطوم في تحديدا في حي ابو ادم هذا هنا
هنالك هدوء حذر يحاول المواطنون هنا
الحصول على الخبز خاصه وان هنالك اصطفاف
لهذا في هذا المخزب المخبز للحصول على
حاجاتهم من الخبز وهي من السلع الضروريه
التي اصابها جحف يحاول كثير من المواطنين
الحصول على هذا الامر ويبدو ان هنالك
الكثير من الصعاب في هذا الاطار الوضع
متازم وصعوبه انجاز وحركه في التنقلات
الداخليه الحمد لله يعني الصفوف متازمة
كما ترى في الصوره
كثير من الناس معانا يعني حتى لو اخذت اخذ
الكميه الكامله يعني حصه المواطن من الخبز
محدوده يعني لا يستطيع المواطنه يشتري
الكميه من الخبز التي يريدها في مثل هذه
الظروف حتى تتاح الفرصه لاكبر عدد من
المواطنين بس نحن بجد مشكلتنا في انه
الكاش نجيبه من وين يعني دي المشكله
الاساسيه يعني نحن بنطالب الاطراف
المتنازعه سواء كان الفريق برهان او
الفريق انه الناس زي ما هم مهتموا بانه
الجاليات الاجنبيه دي كلها ويامنونا
المسارات الامنه نحن بنطلب انه بس يدورون
عشره في المئه من الاهتمام الاجانب دول
المواطنين عشان احنا نقدر نقلي ناسنا
المرضانين والجثث الموجوده في الشوارع
ونحن زادنا نقدر نحن المواد يجينا في
الافران ويجينا في المحلات التجاريه نحن
دايرين اهتمام من الجهاز لانه مسؤولين
الدوله ربنا بيسالهم مننا نحنا طلع الوضع
متضرر جدا يعني بنحي هذه الحرب يعني
اظن برهان يعني ما يفوز احنا المتضررين
بالنسبه للحكم للسلطه اي واحد يفوز لا نحن
المتضررين حاصل ده انت شايف بعينك الحاصل
شنو هذه هي طبيعه الامور والتداعيات الحرب
التي انعكست بشكل وهم يقولون انها سيئه
ولكن تتصاعد وترتفع اصوات المناشدات لوقف
هذه الحرب